degrom begins the night with a streak of
28 consecutive scoreless innings dating
back to last season it's the longest
streak of his career here comes jd
martinez now at a great start but his
own for his last 11.
lunging at that one
into right on the run that one's gonna
be off the wall
up with a nimbo he's gonna fire into
second
jd martinez nearly hit the ball out of
here as he slams that one into the fence
for a double he one-handed this ball a
little slider i think that he got it
goes to show you the kind of power and
he goes to show you it's summertime
fellas jeff mcneal a couple of two-hit
games in a row
well i think they wanted to put it pokes
one the other way and he's got to base
it
first ball fastball hitting right there
mcneal now four for six when he puts the
first pitch into play this year
pete alonso and he takes one the other
way for a base hit mcneil pulls in at
second so back to opposite field hits
for mcneil and alonso and the mets of
something working in the first well the
mets already have more hits in this game
than they did the last time they faced
native aldi
and conforto drives one under right for
a base in mcneil had to hold up it's
bobbled and right filled by verduga but
mcneil had already broken it down and he
pulls in at third so three straight
first pitch singles in the mids of the
base is loaded with one out dom smith
will get into bat with the bases loaded
and one out
and dom grounds one to the right side
moorland to second for one relay not in
time as the run comes home and the mets
take the early lead ball does not hard
enough to turn two and degrom is trying
to match that
we'll top her off the batter for dugo
the grom can't get it but canoe does
with a glow flip and a good stretch by
alonso and they get verdugo for the
second out
neatly done by canoe with back-to-back
sliders both of which were unhittable
and it's owen too
and he's got it as he blows away perez
with a 100 mile an hour fastball here's
andres simenes making his first big
league start he's played in every game
for the met so far this year 2-2 coming
to jimenez and he lines one the other
way andres jimenez has his first big
league hit
then intend he cuts it off and jimenez
going to left center field picks up that
initial
knock
did he offer
he swung the bat and that's it that is
strike three jake with two scoreless
innings tonight now with 30 consecutive
scoreless innings
and bradley no match for that change-up
from degrom for his second strikeout
well he gets his strikeouts in in
bunches doesn't he he just got two in a
row now
and there's another one to strike out
lynn so three strikeouts in a row for
degrom against the lower third and there
are two out of the inning varying his
hold times ben intend he runs rivera's
throw is a good one and canoe with the
tag and he's out at second base sitting
over brandon nimmo over one he is fly to
left here's the pitch that is a beauty
from vivaldi's strike three called on
the inside corner almost had two seam
action started off the plate and then
faded in over the black devils with a
fly out first trip to center field
here's three strikeouts so far and that
one's torn into down the line that's
gonna go all the way to the wall
devers with another double for himself
in fact that's in four straight games
now
yeah he got that change up up and he did
some work to it and now mitch moreland
he's old for one fly to left
he drives it out to center nimmo chasing
back he got a late start and it beats
him over his head and degrum will give
up a run
moreland with the double drives
endeavors
and degrom's streak
ends at 31 consecutive scoreless innings
the last time jacob degrom gave up a run
was last september the 9th when wilmer
flores hit a home run against
that gets through here comes moreland
and mitch marlon will slide in safe the
red sox have taken the lead
degrom with a little bit of a walk on
the wild side in this setting and
boston's in front two to one he's been
spiking that slider a lot this inning
and got away with a couple of them
to jackie bradley
bradley fou tips the change up for
strike three and that's the fourth
strike out of the night for de grom but
now andres ximena's up for the third
time and then has picked up his first
big league hit
jimenez strikes one out to center back
goes bradley he can't get two and then
it rolls to the center field
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
his first rbi and he's given the vets
the lead it's three to two new york in
the sixth vasquez next over two so far
one out in the seventh
drives that one deep to left field that
one's sailing back there and it's gone
into the seats
christian vasquez with his second home
run of the season and the red sox have
tied it 3-3 he got him he got him
hanging breaking ball 2-2 and he lost it
dope it is up to mitch moreland
going after the first pitch soft roller
charging it mcnealy lost the handle on
it a run in to score
and the red sox have retaken the lead
for three not taking anything you can
get that little squibbler down the line
he had no chance on that play even if he
bare hands it so the base is reloaded
the red sox in front 4-3 here's vasquez
and a shot base hit into right field one
run in
here comes the second run two-run score
martinez touching home plate vazquez
comes through again and the red sox lead
it six to three or a beautiful thing
shoots that ball down the other way and
after going bridge the last time up he
gets a fastball sespedes is one for
three tonight at a base in the fourth
inning
and he drives this one toward the left
field corner tent toward the wall and
it's out of here
[Music]
a lightning bolt to left precess for
this and it's now six to four boston is
davis
strikeout victim and is only at bat
tonight with the bases loaded grounded
toward the
stuttered by debra's from his knees the
throat knowing tyler what comes home
denver's kept the game from being tied
by smothering that ball but the mets
with the infield single by davis get
within a run here comes cespedes one run
game
at citi field two walks two singles in
the inning
swing and a miss he got him he struck
him out two gone
big pitch
best curve ball down that's the one you
want
robinson canoe he has singled each of
his last two times up
little floater backing up he's got it
perazo with the catch and the red sox
win it
six to five the final as they snap the
four game skid here tonight